buonasera a tutti
vi è mai capitato da giovani divenire
interrotti mentre provate ad inserirvi
all'interno di un discorso fra adulti
come vi siete sentiti ed adulti lo avete
mai fatto nei confronti dei ragazzi
perché tenete a mente le vostre risposte
a me è capitato molte volte divenire
interrotta mentre provava inserirmi
all'interno di un discorso di economia
di politica o di attualità
con la scusa di essere come diceva prima
christian troppo giovane per che a 16
anni in tu non puoi avere una tua idea
sull'attualità invece la mia idea ce
l'avevo e volevo condividerla con voi
adulti non mi avete dato in molti casi
la possibilità in questo mio talk e
desidero farvi capire come invece l'idea
che noi abbiamo di una generazione
in particolare della mia generazione è
l'idea che voi avete di noi non c'è una
verità assoluta e sia piuttosto
un'immagine non del tutto corretta
bisogna farvi anche ragionare su
un'altra questione ovvero l'importanza
dell'ascolto generazionale per fare
questo dobbiamo partire un po indietro
nel tempo potrebbe sembrare un paradosso
lo so parlare di una generazione degli
anni 2000 e partire dalla storia
dell'uomo però fidatevi vi servirà a
capire
nel corso della storia possiamo dire che
se l'uomo è riuscito ad uscire dalla sua
comfort zone sostanzialmente per due
motivi ovvero il desiderio di cambiare
la realtà in cui viveva e la curiosità
possiamo dire che la speranza in un
nuovo inizio ha rappresentato una
caratteristica dell'uomo fin dal
principio e quindi è grazie a queste due
caratteristiche che l'uomo è riuscito a
uscire dalla grotta per andare alla
rivista
cerca di una realtà diversa
ha cominciato ad interagire con la
natura fino arrivare a dominarla
facciamo ora un salto nel presente
perché se vi raccontassi l'evoluzione
dell'uomo dei tempi della grotta ad oggi
sarebbe una cosa molto lunga
quindi tenete a mente adesso la
generazione del presente
oggigiorno la speranza in un nuovo
inizio sembra aver perso la sua naturale
spontaneità infatti non si fa più di
tanto per cambiare lo status attuale
delle cose ci si aspetta piuttosto che
sia l'altra cambiarle ea cambiare anche
se stesso e l'altro siamo proprio noi i
cosiddetti millennio ovvero tutti quei
ragazzi nati a partire dagli anni 80 per
arrivare a primi anni duemila
siamo anche la generazione che viene
definita la generazione y teoricamente
gli adulti ci vorrebbero come
protagonisti di un nuovo inizio di un
cambiamento ma per loro siamo anche la
generazione che più viene disprezzata la
generazione che viene definita senza
valori e alcune volte anche come la
generazione di fannulloni secondarie
cento in studi invece siamo la
generazione più istruita della storia
siamo la generazione che è cresciuta con
le forti immagini del crollo delle torri
gemelle e con il suono delle voci rotte
di nonni e bisnonni che pur di
trasmetterci l'idea in cui realmente
credono e per cui hanno anche combattuto
vivono con angoscia le atrocità della
guerra ed io questa cosa la vivo ogni
qualvolta la mia bisnonna mi racconta
com'era vivere la guerra nella
quotidianità che cosa voleva dire veder
partire il proprio fratello per il
fronte senza sapere se le avrebbe mai
più rivisto e quali emozioni ha provato
invece quando l'ha visto tornare
siamo anche la generazione che è
cresciuta in un momento in cui
l'immigrazione in italia era già un
fenomeno consistente
infatti siamo stati abituati fin da
piccoli ad interagire con ragazzi
provenienti da altre parti del mondo
senza nessunissimo problema
questo studio sottolinea il fatto che la
paura del diverso di cui tanto oggi si
parla denominandola come xenofobia
in realtà se una paura comune a tutti
gli esseri viventi
perché di fatto paura del diverso è
sinonimo di ciò che non
conosco ed è inevitabile che abbia paura
che qualcosa che non conosco nel
millennio spero questo sentimento questa
paura è meno forte perché siamo stati
abituati ogni giorno ad abbattere i muri
ad andare incontro all'altro
siamo anche come sapete benissimo la
generazione dei nativi digitali quella
che utilizza i social per mettersi in
contatto con il mondo
siamo la generazione che è cresciuta in
un momento in cui l'inquinamento
ambientale era già un problema e non
solamente un fenomeno allarmante come
invece è stato presentato ai nostri
genitori
quindi non è un caso che ancora una
volta siamo noi la generazione che più
sensibile ai temi dell'ecologia e della
sostenibilità ambientale
credo perché queste caratteristiche che
vi ho appena elencato e della nostra
conoscenza della storia
potremmo essere in grado di cambiare le
cose se solo qualcuno cominciasse a
credere un po di più in noi da parte
nostra dobbiamo cominciare già da ora ad
essere delle persone coinvolte
la cittadinanza attiva perché la nostra
speranza più grande è quella di poter
dire un giorno di vivere in una società
che rispecchiano ideali in cui noi
realmente crediamo che sono ideali di
libertà di giustizia di rispetto e di
accoglienza del diverso che come abbiamo
imparato da piccoli tanto diverso da noi
non è la nostra più grande speranza è
quello di sentirci parte di un gruppo un
gruppo che ha voglia di cambiare le cose
non si tratta necessariamente di un
insieme di persone che ha gli stessi
valori gli stessi diari le stesse idee
anzi più le nostre idee saranno diverse
che si verrà a creare una situazione di
dialogo e quindi mettendo in discussione
innanzitutto le nostre idee e poi noi
come persona si riuscirà a fare la
rivoluzione
desidero citare in questo momento un
personaggio che mi ha ispirato molto e
mi ha dato la fonte di ispirazione per
questo talk lui e don luigi ciotti e in
un incontro organizzato dalla mia scuola
ha detto ragazzi
diffidate dai navigatori solitari e o di
questa frase brevissima ne ho fatto
riflessioni lunghissimo perché se ci
pensate è vero io sono uno sono soltanto
una ma sono una e quindi posso essere
la scintilla che fa iniziare la
rivoluzione non posso sicuramente parla
da sola ma posso dare un nuovo inizio
credo che tutti voi conoscerete la
teoria farfalla ovvero la teoria secondo
la quale lo spostamento dell'area
provocato dal battito delle ali di una
farfalla in una determinata parte della
terra possa scatenare dalla parte
opposta
un uragano e io vorrei rappresentare la
vostra farfalla vorrei dare inizio ad
una rivoluzione perché potrebbe anche
non sembrare ma io come tutti gli altri
ragazzi siamo interessati ai temi di
attualità di politica di economia
desideriamo capire desideriamo
ricrederci perché siamo stanchi che ci
venga presentato solamente casus belli
vogliamo capire quali sono le cause
profonde quali è il contesto che sta
dietro ad un fenomeno a una guerra o
qualsiasi cosa sia desideriamo capire
qual è il contesto sociale qual è il
contesto culturale e anche religioso e
per fare questo abbiamo anche bisogno
del vostro aiuto perché secondo me è
importante che nelle scuole si comincia
a parlare di attualità perché dobbiamo
cominciare ad avere la nostra idea
l'aiuto dell'adulto dovrebbe consistere
solamente nel indirizzarci verso
un'analisi oggettiva dei fatti senza
impedirci di avere una visione ampia sul
mondo che ci circonda dovrebbe
sostanzialmente insegnarci la strategia
per arrivare alla verità delle cose e
questo secondo me è fondamentale perché
solo così si verrà a creare una
generazione che in grado di cambiare le
cose
desidero diciamo presentarmi un secondo
problema ovvero quello che vi ho
anticipato all'inizio la mancanza di
ascolto generazionale lo sapete
benissimo che stiamo affrontando gravi
problemi la società ormai tanti problemi
che non si riescono a risolvere
qual è la soluzione io non ce l'ho però
ho la strategia secondo me dovrebbe
risolvere le cose ovvero voi siete una
generazione che ha moltissima esperienza
soprattutto dal punto di vista manovale
invece siamo una generazione che hanno
nuova visione
del mondo vediamo le cose in un modo
totalmente nuovo e quindi credo che la
cooperazione potrebbe essere necessaria
se non indispensabile lo so che quando
ci criticateci riprendete non lo fate
con cattiveria
anzi siete davvero convinti che noi ci
stiamo sbagliando che le nostre idee non
sono valide perché sostanzialmente
pensate se funzionato per me allora
funzionerà anche per mio figlio
per ora sbagliate o meglio il vostro
ragionamento non è del tutto corretto
noi viviamo in un momento in cui si è
verificato un cambio generazionale
foltissimo forse quello più forte della
storia
se ci pensate quando voi avevate la mia
taquan dove avevate 16 anni la realtà e
la società era totalmente diversa quindi
pensare che quello che andava bene per
voi possa andare bene
trent'anni dopo in una realtà totalmente
diversa forse non è la chiave per
risolvere le cose e se ci pensate è è
questo che manca la società ovvero non
c'è un dialogo fra le due generazioni
molto diverse fra loro vi voglio
lasciare con un messaggio o con uno
spunto di riflessione credo che sia
necessario che cominciamo ad ascoltarci
a vicenda e solo così riusciremo
imparare moltissimo l'uno dall'altro e
forse anche risolvere i problemi della
società grazie